this is pretty stunning news I have to
say I just wasn't expecting this I
completely blindsided Tim Ryan has ended
his presidential campaign I am floored I
think like everybody else i yesterday
when this was announced I left my house
and I saw people walking through the
streets in a daze all of their hopes and
dreams dashed in an instant because
without the promise without the promise
of a Tim Ryan presidency what point is
there any more what what reason do we
have to continue what hope do we have
where do we go next
also follow-up question who the hell is
Tim Ryan and I suppose now we'll never
find out and and that maybe is the
greatest tragedy in all of this okay
moving though from tragedy to I think a
good outcome at least as good of an
outcome as we could have hoped for the
judge in the james-younger case has
effectively nullified the jury verdict
by giving a father joint conservatorship
over his son which includes having a say
in the boys quote transition you
remember earlier in the week the jury
decision gave the mother full custody
and the ability to make all the
decisions including medical decisions
which means that she could facilitate
this quote/unquote transition of her son
into a girl the judge though I suppose
has basically overturned that and said
that no the father will will have a say
which is which is good as I said it's
it's as good of an outcome as I think we
could have reasonably hoped for now it's
not all good she did gag the father and
the mother so they can't talk to the
media she kicked all the media out of
the courtroom before giving this verdict
although I'm told by LifeSite news life
site news and a website called the Texan
have both been following this case
they've been on the ground they're
reporting on it and for most of the time
doing great work reporting on this case
and for almost all that time the mass
media had no interest in the case
whatsoever for the last few days the
media has been paying more attention
because we sort of forced them the
pay attention but so you can imagine
their outrage I was you know just
listening to some of the LifeSite people
for example imagine their outrage that
they've been following this case now we
get to the to the moment the big moment
and they're kicked out of the courtroom
while according to a life cite reporter
a a camera from one of the people from I
think the local CBS affiliate was
invited into the good they were allowed
to be there but all the reporters that
had been there the whole time they
couldn't be there so that's no good but
at least the father will have some
ability now to protect his son which is
obviously what we were fighting for and
at the same time we not only force the
media to take it pay attention to this
issue but we got the you know the Texas
governor took notice of it various other
people in positions of power here's the
thing though the public cannot be
mobilized every time a child a child's
gender confusion is encouraged and
amplified by his abusive parents this is
happening more and more in this country
as more and more minors follow the trend
of identifying as transgender because
I'm sure it's just a coincidence gender
ism is a is a natural phenomenon we're
told but somehow coincidentally as it's
talked about more and and and been more
accepted in the media it becomes this
trendy thing you've got more and more
miners that discover that they're
transgender what a coincidence but as
this is happening we're not going to be
able to protect them all from being
prescribed puberty blockers which is a
chemical castration and we're not gonna
be able to do this every single time
there's a case like this especially
because in most of these cases you don't
have one of the parents trying to step
in to stop it
in most these cases either there's
there's one parent doing it the other
one's not in the picture the dad's not
in the picture I suspect that's the case
a lot of the time or
both parents are on board with abusing
their child and turning them into some
other gender and this is why Republicans
and Congress need to act
now's the time to do it it is it is
there is no situation where it could
ever be morally ethically medically
scientifically justified to give a
physically healthy child drugs
suppressing his normal development
simply because he's confused about his
biological identity there's never a time
where that is not a horrific Olear Ong
and deranged and abusive thing to do to
a child and so it shouldn't be hard for
Republicans in the Senate to come up
with a bill that bans the chemical
castration of children you can even call
it that in the bill the anti child
castration amendment or whatever you
want to call it and it would be a very
accurate way of describing the bill it
would be a bill that who could it would
be a very politically risky thing for
the Democrats to oppose a bill like that
I'm sure they would and let them do it
let them come out and explain let them
make the case for child castration
Republicans if they have any sense
they'll put the Democrats in the
position of having to do that alright
moving on again the the Katie hill story
it's interesting that there's been kind
of a saga this week because we started
this week which feels now like it
started five years ago but we started
the week talking about the Katy Hill
scandal and james-younger and remarking
about how the media wasn't paying
attention to either case now at the end
of the week these are two of the biggest
stories in the country and I think
that's at least partly because we forced
the media to pay attention to these
stories as for Hill the story has also
been helped along significantly by
yesterday a Daily Mail article published
which contains a whole mess of new
photographs and text messages which the
Daily Mail quote obtained they don't
specify how exactly some of these
pictures are again of Hill sons clothing
in various compromising positions one
shows her with a bomb and it reveals
strangely enough
what appears to be an iron cross tattoo
and she's naked in that picture and
there are there are even more photos
that the Daily Mail says they have but
they haven't published and those sound
like they're even more explicit shall we
say the twenty to twenty-two year old
female staffer that she was sexually
involved with has also been revealed and
her name's been put out there I'm not
gonna mention her name because I don't
think it's relevant and the new photos
have whereas the first photo that came
out of Hill naked brushing some staffers
hair the the the face of the staffer was
blurred out now we've got all these
pictures in it and the face is not
blurred out anymore they're they're
putting that out there
all right with all this new stuff I
think there are two issues one is the
fact that Hill has been involved in this
activity activity which as I've argued
throughout the week is unethical and a
minimum potentially illegal certainly
dangerous as it opens her up to
blackmail and extortion by America's
enemies I was also interested to see
that apparently Hill started this
relationship with the staffer before she
was hired on the campaign as far as I
know the Daily Mail they're the first
person that they're the first outlet to
report that fact because the timeline
was never completely clear so Hill
according to the Daily Mail Hill got
involved with this staffer and then
hired her on so Hill was paying a sex
partner thousands in campaign funds
without disclosing the relationship
which is a clear misuse of funds a clear
scandal and yes it is relevant to the
public and yes Hill should resign
because of it we could also talk about
the hypocrisy that many people have
pointed out considering that she was a
vocal critic of Kavanagh and a proponent
of the me2 movement and yet this is how
she was carrying on carrying on this way
with subordinates which if that doesn't
count as workplace sexual harassment at
a minimum
then I don't know what does you want to
talk about sexual harassment well if if
what we are seeing now documented if
that doesn't count as sexual harassment
then I don't know how you could ever
accuse anybody of it but there's a
second issue here too which I think
complicates matters slightly and that is
the fact that these personal photos this
revenge porn essentially was released to
the media and published in the first
place now a couple of these pictures
were apparently actually posted online
on a forum where spouses shared naked
pictures of each other with the world
and that's a thing now that people do I
don't know if she--if Hill knew that
those photos were going on that forum I
assume she did I'm not sure but this
goes back to when she was still with her
husband because she was with her husband
and this this other girl at the same
time at any rate if naked pictures of a
US Congress member are willingly posted
on a public forum well then I'd say you
can't blame the public for taking notice
and if she knew that that particular
picture was going up online and she was
okay with it and now that picture is
everywhere online well that's on her
that's her fault but many of these
pictures were not so far as I'm aware
posted anywhere with Katie Hills
knowledge they were for malicious
reasons given to the media and that is
wrong and potentially illegal as revenge
porn is illegal against the law in like
40 states so I think it's important to
strike a balance with this story
originally you had the one leaked
photograph with the younger woman's face
blurred out and it was just that but now
someone is releasing volumes and volumes
apparently of salacious explicit
pornographic photos without obviously
the consent of Katie Hill or her
knowledge and we have to say yes what it
reveals about Hill is highly problematic
troubling unethical potentially illegal
but the
lise of the photos is also all of those
things problematic troubling unethical
potentially illegal and I think that's a
balancing act that's important to get
right here
because I don't think we want to be in a
position of endorsing revenge porn and
it's not because look I'm not sitting
here trying to take the moral high
ground looking down on all the peons who
know it's it's this is right I think we
could all agree that revenge porn is a
bad thing we're not fans of that we're
not putting our stamp of approval on
that but when when someone even if they
do it illegally when they release
information even even if it's
information that we shouldn't know it's
kind of like the the email thing with
the Democrats in 2016 all these emails
were coming out well yeah we we
shouldn't those emails shouldn't have
been hacked and they never should have
been published in the first place but
they were and so now we know these
things and that matters we can't pretend
we don't know it so yes maybe these
photos never should have ended up online
in the first place but they did and so
now we know that she was doing that with
her subordinates and paying them with
campaign funds and that that matters and
so sure she could look she could go and
pursue legal penalties and and all of
that find out who leaked the photos and
yeah I don't I don't blame her for do it
if I was her I'd do the same thing but
at the same time she should be kicked
out of Congress because this is to call
this inappropriate behavior from a US
Congresswoman you would be way way WAY
understating it one other note in this
just I have to also mention I think
probably what a lot of people thinking
is what what kind of husband posts naked
pictures of his own wife online I'm
talking about the one that was posted
when they were together the one that
again presumably she knew was put up but
what kind
emasculated cuckolded a pathetic excuse
for a man do you have to be to give
other men a picture of your own naked
wife to be used as pornography that's
that's a if this guy was in a position
where he could be thrown out of
somewhere or impeached or I think he'd
deserve it too because that is so
pathetic
all right now for the requisites war on
Halloween topic you got to do one of
these every year so as we get ready for
Halloween the daily wire has an article
up right now by Paul Bois reading in
part according to Yahoo lifestyle the
Evanston Skokie School District 65 in
the Chicago suburb of Evanston Illinois
announced last month the Halloween
celebrations alienate certain members of
the staff and student body who do not
participate for religious or personal
reasons as well as those who cannot
afford costumes as part of our school
and district-wide commitment to equity
we are focused on building community and
creative inclusive welcoming
environments for all the statement from
the superintendent read while we
recognize that Halloween is a fun
tradition for many it is not a Hallett
holiday that is celebrated by everyone
for various reasons and we want to honor
that we are also aware of the range of
inequities that are embedded in
Halloween celebrations that take place
as part of the school day and the
unintended negative impact that it can
have on some students families and staff
as a result we are moving away from
Halloween celebrations that include
costumes and similar traditions during
the school day we are confident our
school communities will find new and
engaging ways to build community within
their schools a range of inequities
embedded in Halloween yes that's exactly
what I think when I open the door for
trick-or-treaters on Halloween kids
knock on my door I open it well look at
this range of inequities you bunch of
filthy bigots get off my porch
dad here you Nazis I know we all respond
that way that is not at all a really
weird way to look at Halloween is it a
range of inequities inequities and
iniquities too if I if I could mention
and then the article
he's over at Vermont's Burlington school
district English let's see English
learning director of programs Miriam
Earth's system Kading wait at Tisch am
eh te sha em - ca t ing Miriam at - sham
Caden told local reporters about the
fear that people have over culturally
insensitive costumes many people are
made uncomfortable by the notion that
you change your identity hold on we're
back up okay so this is a sham Kaeding
talking about the problem Halloween many
people are made uncomfortable by the
notion that you change your identity you
turn into someone else
and those somebody else's could
represent cultural appropriations yes
this is a very troubling aspect of
Halloween you've got all these people
changing their identities becoming
witches and werewolves and vampires all
different identities that's the other
thing when I opened my door Halloween
there's only trick-or-treaters and I and
I look at them and I say you frauds
you're not really a Power Ranger this is
a fraud over here identity theft that's
what I say
hey you yeah you're not Frankenstein
hold on say what's the big idea here
actually wait I think there's a word
there's a word for changing your
identity on in a festive way as part of
a holiday tradition there's a word for
it what is that it's it's it's what sort
yes it's called a costume isn't that
yeah you costume anyway I think there's
a word for people who get offended by
children's Halloween costumes yes that
word is is a it's all the time either
idiot is the word half-wit [ __ ] dunce
imbecilic overly sensitive puritanical
humorless tedious party pooping
ridiculous loudmouth mutton-headed
scolds is another was more than one word
but all of those words really would work
for
I how there's a part of me that's so
badly you ever seen magical school bus
you know magical school bus
great great show at least the original
they've got a new version a Magic School
Bus out now it's all my kids watching it
and I made him turn it off because it
was such a disgrace compared to the
older the better version anyway I've
always this apart me he's always wanted
to get into a Magic School Bus
and if I could go into the mind of
someone like this someone like a Miriam
at the Sham caning just to see what's
going on in there if anything but I
really want to understand maybe I don't
but I don't know maybe going into the
such a mind would be like entering into
a black hole so maybe you but how could
you how could you even see Halloween in
these terms that's culturally
insensitive stealing identities
III can't even imagine looking at it
that way alright so I wanted to chime in
on one more solder before we get the
emails a Washington Post columnist I've
been wanting to talk about this for a
couple of weeks but it other news has
gotten in the way a Washington Post
columnist wrote a piece a couple weeks
ago they got a fair amount of attention
he argues that well the headline is poor
service you still have to tip twenty
percent no matter what have to and he
goes on to say that it's our
responsibility it's always typically
twenty percent in every situation even
if we get bad service because the people
who work on tips depend on it for
survival and they don't get paid a
living wage
do they need the tips so you have to
COFF COFF it up and that's the argument
it's a familiar one you hear any time
he's talking about tips and people who
are have been in the service engine
industry working it now or have worked
in it this is the argument you always
hear they they point out that your
waiter probably isn't getting paid much
of an hourly wage he or she needs the
tips and so that's why you have to do
I myself have worked in a service
industry in many capacities and I still
say that that attitude is BS first of
all by this logic when you go to a car
dealership you have to buy the most
expensive car you can possibly afford
because the salesman depends on that
Commission there might as well be a
Washington Post column arguing that hey
if you could get a better Oh you could
get a better deal on a car too bad
pay full price because a lot of car
salesmen they only get paid on
Commission I think pretty much that's
the case for pretty much every car
salesman unless they're also a manager
or something I'm pretty sure that
certainly many of them most of them
don't get paid much of a wage other than
the commission that they earn and they
might only sell 10 or 12 cars in a month
if that and they really don't make a
whole lot on each car contrary to
popular belief unless you're at a
high-end dealership buying Lamborghinis
or something these people are not making
your average car sale you might only
make the equivalent of minimum wage so
is it your ethical duty then to to spend
as much as you can to make sure that he
has enough to eat
I suppose that would be a nice thing to
do but is it your responsibility would
anyone actually do that no obviously
that would be crazy
and if you take this logic and extend it
you've just made it so that every
consumer during an average day of
errands and shopping has a moral
responsibility to be bankrupt by the end
of it here's what I'll say for tipping I
actually do almost always tip waiters
and foodservice people in the
foodservice
delivery people and waiters anyway I
almost always tip at least 20% I've done
both of those jobs myself I do have an
affinity for those people I have an
empathy for them and so and it's just
you know it this is also something that
becomes generational I think my dad was
a big tipper his dad was a big it's it's
kind of passed down I think through the
male line the tipping and so if your dad
was a good tipper then you're probably a
good tipper if your dad wasn't I
my theory maybe I'll do a paper on that
so maybe someone should do a study on
that so I generally will tip 20% 20% is
my minimum not because I have to or I
have some kind of moral responsibility
or because I owe it to the person that's
handing me my food it's just I want to
so I do and if the service is really
good then I might tip I could go up to
30 but I can go up to 40% I can go up to
50 if I'm if I'm really feeling generous
and you really blew my socks off with
with your service then I know sky's the
limit
point is if you're serving me and I tip
you and this is just a hint that if you
if you work in the service industry and
I ever happened to come sit down in your
restaurant you're serving me and I tip
you less than 20% that's a hint that you
were really really really bad you have
to really earn it for me to give a bad
tip I think I've maybe I've given no tip
maybe two or three times in my life and
that was only because the service was so
miserably aggressively bad that I had no
choice I felt like I was backed into a
corner and I could not justify leaving
even one cent as much as I wanted to I
couldn't but usually for run-of-the-mill
bad service I'll give out 10 or 15% and
I but I also try to because this is one
of the reasons why I don't penalize on
tips as often as some people do is
because having done these jobs I realize
that many times the things that we get
mad at the waiters for foods coming out
late you get your appetizer at the same
time as your entree that really annoys
me I hate that you order your steak
medium-rare but it comes out well done
most of that stuff that goes to the
kitchen that probably wasn't the waiters
fault
and so to penalize the waiter for that I
think is not fair all that said the
problem though and again that's that's
it's it but it's not an entitlement
thing so if you feel entitled to the tip
even even if I if my baseline is 20 you
still have to earn it
and the advantage to working in a
something based on tips is that you can
yeah means that you're not getting the
the hourly wage that some people are
getting but it's really up to you I
think if you if you're if you're getting
if it's a busy night if you're working
at a restaurant and it's a busy night if
it's not a busy night people aren't
coming in then yeah you're not gonna
make much money you can't do much about
that but if it's a busy night and you're
getting tables and you're constantly
getting stiffed on tips that probably
just means that you're a bad at what
you're doing but it could be a lot
better it doesn't take much really be
energetic be cheerful not that I'm one
to speak about being cheerful but I
don't do that for a living so be
energetic be cheerful be helpful all
that if you just do that and you can
pretty much guarantee 20% tips from most
people if not more it's one of the
reasons I was a deliverer I delivered
pizzas for a long time a long time I
don't know maybe a year and it was one
it's probably my favorite of those kinds
of jobs as if all the jobs I had as a
teenager that was by far my favorite job
and I liked the fact that it was based
on tips because I knew that look if I
could just get there on time or even a
little bit early and I'm super friendly
for those for that one minute exchange I
can I can really generate those tips and
I kind of like that all that said the
problem is that everyone now in our
economy tries to get a tip out of you
every coffee shop you go to every cafe
every eatery places where the person
behind the counter is just ringing you
up and handing you your order they're
not waiting on the table they're not
cleaning up after you that thing they're
just you tell them what they want they
what you want they punch it in and then
they and then this is what is in every
coffee shop now seems like they flip
that little iPad thing around after you
put the card in and then it pops up you
want to give a 15% to 20% tip 30% tip
you're asking me for your you're
suggesting that I give you a 30% tip for
handing me a coffee come on wait you're
this is what you're doing this is this
is the whole job your I say oh can I get
a medium medium roast coffee
hit it in there turn around hold up the
cup bring it around hand the cup 30% for
that come on you better be pretty damn
friendly you better be not just pretty
you you you better be the most the
friendliest person I've ever encountered
in my life in order for that to warrant
30 percent so that's my only problem
with the tipping is I think we need to
every every day now of life is is has
become like a stay at a high-end hotel
you ever stated a really high-end hotel
where everybody everyone's very nice and
they're all very helpful everybody you
encounter wants a tip and so even if
you're lucky enough to go sometimes I'll
travel and you know I do speaking events
and so and sometimes someone's very
generous I put you put you up in a
really nice hotel but what it ends up
being is it ends up costing you $10,000
because you'd have to tip everybody all
you just you're just handing out cash to
everyone as you walk through the lobby
or just throwing dollar bills everywhere
and that's what it's like in life now
everywhere you go everyone expects a tip
it's just it's gotten a little too much
and that as my cheapskate rant for the
day ok let's go to emails Matt Walsh
show at gmail.com Matt Walsh show at
gmail.com from Christine says hey Matt
thanks for you you're addressing the
whole breastfeeding and stigma on your
show yes Thursday and an even bigger
thanks for not comparing it to public
urination like some people sometimes do
one is an unsent sanitary waste product
one keeps infants alive I agree that
that comparison is I think unwarranted
also a little creepy in a number of ways
your comparison to feet however is just
a bit off it's not illegal to show your
feet in public we wear shoes in public
places because feet are dirty without
they pick up everything we walk on and
keeping them covered in such places as a
health measure in addition to preventing
someone from suing a place for injuring
themselves by stepping on a nail breasts
aren't being dragged around on the
ground okay I'm gonna
there are so many jokes I contemplated
making I'm just gonna move on go to a
beach and you and you show your feet no
problem go topless in America and you
will have the cops cult hang your feet
on a window driving down the highway
have you hang your feet out of a window
driving down the highway and you have a
country song well you also have a ticket
if you do that not to mention you get
into an accident with your CIA see
people drive it on the highway with the
feet hanging I was like do you realize
what's gonna happen to you if you have
to if the driver has to stop short do
you realize what's where your leg is
going most of your bodies go into the
windshield your legs going out that way
just so you know hang your feet out okay
hang your breasts out of the window and
you're a sex offender as for well it
really depends on where you are I
suppose with some of this stuff as for
covering up to each their own someone
someone feels safer covering for others
it's just an extra burden and it's
faster and easier not to do you think
Mary covered Jesus up in the heat of the
Middle East to preserve modesty very
doubtful he would have had a heat stroke
overall you didn't dig your hole in the
subject too deep
I've breastfed five children and you
have never been a pro or and have never
been approached or told to cover up I
think the stigma is in a social circle
people choose to run it okay so I didn't
dig my hole in the breast fitting so
they're too deep let me try again my
only issue with your response Christine
is that you're talking about the breadth
of the comfort level of the
breastfeeding mother and that's good
because there should be a comfort level
and and as I said yesterday
breastfeeding should not be stigmatized
it doesn't seem to me that it really is
but if it is it shouldn't be a women in
women shouldn't be prevented from doing
it there's nothing bad or shameful about
it obviously it's a healthy good thing
for a woman to do so I'm on board with
you there and as I said yesterday my
wife is currently breastfeeding our new
baby and has just as she has just as she
did for the three other babies that
we've had but I also think that even if
you don't want to call it modesty it's
just maybe a matter of basic politeness
to at least take into consideration
everybody else so can you meet me
halfway can we agree
that you're focusing on well it's up to
the woman what does you want to do and
right okay but also in general in life
we should take into account the people
around us and try to be considerate to
some degree right within reason and you
know we've all been out in public in
situations where a woman just for lack
of a better term sort of whips it out
not a care in the world
feeds does the the thing you know around
everyone no cover no attempt at all even
slightly to be discreet so I think we've
all been in scenarios like that and I
think that's kind of absurd there's no
reason to go out of your way to show off
so as long as we can agree that there
should be some kind of balance that
there should be some element of
discreteness and and taking into account
other people and and and so hopefully we
can agree on that and then everything
everything will be everything will be
fine
okay from Simon Says hi man have you
seen a quiet place I have seen it and
it's a great film and I'll tell you the
thing I really liked it I liked
everything about that movie honestly but
the thing that I including just the way
that they handled suspense in a horror
movie that doesn't rely on gore and it
doesn't even rely on jump scares all
that much is there some of that but but
not as much it really is just building
suspense psychological suspense which I
appreciate but I also really appreciate
it in that movie the way that the father
character is portrayed as a good heroic
father who loves and sacrifices for his
family so I like that movie a lot from
Lawrence says hi Matt I listen your show
all the time but this is my first time
emailing I think you've what you've said
about three-year-olds not knowing what
gender means is absolutely correct I
think that sometimes a kid might say
they're a boy or a girl because they
want to be a part of something boys or
girls are doing I have a 12 year old
girl and a nine year old boy have to
listen to your show today I remember an
occasion when my son was about three I
was painting my daughter's toenails and
I had painted my own right before my son
said he wanted isn't
pay the two I explained that we had our
nails painted because we were girls and
boys and dollar nail polish then I
started an activity that the three of us
could do together now having a girl and
a boy they both played with dolls trucks
etc and my son has never expressed a
desire to be a girl but probably because
I made it clear to him that he is in
fact a boy you are exactly correct
Lauren and what you just said there is
is so important for people to understand
this is the point that I've been trying
to make that when age a young child says
that they say when a boy for example
says he wants to be a girl what he's
really trying to communicate is that he
wants to do the things he wants to be a
part of something that the girls are
doing and very often the thing that he
wants to be a part of fine let him be a
part of it if you want they're all
sitting around and coloring doing arts
and crafts he wants to do that fine he
wants to play with dolls who cares now I
agree with you with with our boys we're
not gonna paint their toenails or put
them in dresses I think that's going
several steps too far and and that will
create the confusion because on one hand
there's no reason to freak out if your
son picks up a doll you're not gonna put
that doll down stop right there oh
you're not gonna do that
who cares he's got a doll who cares but
it because and that's not gonna confuse
him but you do want to set these
boundaries and help him to understand
who he is and so dressing him up like a
girl is only gonna create confusion you
don't want to do that so I think you've
got the right idea in the right insight
into this and we just can't emphasize
enough that as parents a big part of our
job is to help our children understand
who they are and what they're supposed
to do as people we don't take their cue
we don't sit back to our three-year-olds
and say okay you tell me who you are
what you want to do how your life is
gonna run we don't do that they need us
to step in and show them the way until
we can fling open the doors and let them
fly let them leave the nest
as free birds this is from Shannon says
hi Matt really appreciate your views I
have one question though I hope you
don't take offense to why do you as a
Catholic look to the Catholic Church to
interpret Scripture for you the great
thing about the Reformation in my
opinion is that it empowered and
encouraged people to draw their own
conclusions and not to rely on the
interpretation of fallible humans what
is your take on that
again don't mean this with hostility
well you say you don't mean it with
hostility but Jen and you I take great
offense to this question it hurts my
feelings deeply but I will try to forge
ahead so a few things first just my view
on Scripture it's true that I do trust
the church's interpretation but I also
read the book for myself and and and I
do in a sense draw my own conclusions in
that I don't just look to what the
church tells me I should get out of the
Bible and say well okay that settles it
don't need to read it they've spoon-fed
it to me and I'll take their word for it
no I pick it up and I read it and I see
what I actually do get out of it and I
think and I turn the passages over in my
head I reflect on them and all of that
I'm a huge proponent of doing that a
huge proponent and in fact I will grant
the stereotype that many Catholics in my
experience don't read their Bibles
enough and generally speaking
Protestants are better versed in
Scripture than Catholics are that is not
always true and it is as I said a
stereotype but most many stereotypes are
there for a reason and I think this one
is if I'm being totally honest it's not
uncommon for me now if you want to talk
about the uninformed lazy Catholics I
don't know the Bible but right but they
don't know anything and in price and
churches you have the same thing right
you've got plenty of Christians who are
lackadaisical aren't paying attention
don't read the Bible don't pay attention
to anything and so I'm not even talking
about that I'm talking really about it's
not uncommon for me to encounter highly
educated Catholics who can spit moral
theology at you all day long and they
could tell you all about Aquinas and
Augusta and the Church Fathers and maybe
they can speak very philosophically and
they're very informed about all these
highfalutin thiel
logical concepts and they can give you
theories on the atonement and they can
do all this stuff but and they can give
you church history and they could take
but some of them in my experience they
couldn't tell you what happens in
Matthew's infancy narrative not exactly
anyway so the some of the really basic
biblical stuff they aren't as versed on
and not always the case
but sometimes I have noticed that and
that's a problem and I do think there
should be a greater focus for Catholics
in schools and in churches on reading
the Bible and understanding what it says
now on the other hand so I have granted
that on the other hand this idea that
the Protestant Reformation was all about
people interpreting the Bible's for
themselves I don't see that I don't
think the history of the movement bears
that out I don't claim to be I don't
claim to be an expert in the history of
the Reformation but I have read about it
and I'm fairly familiar with with it and
it seems to me that the guys who were at
the forefront of the Reformation
Lutheran Calvin they had their own
interpretations of the Bible in fact
these men were openly critical of
certain books of the Bible hostile to
them even focusing on Luther for a
minute he is I think most people know he
famously was insulting towards the book
of James he seemed to really hate that
book called it the Epistle of straw he
never explicitly advocated for removing
it from the Canon but I think because he
knew he couldn't get away with that but
he all but did that he said it shouldn't
be taught in schools we said that it's
wrong on a number of points that it you
know it doesn't have a forgiving us
phrase it doesn't have the spirit of the
of God in it or words to that effect
so it's always been interesting to me
that the Reformation was supposed to be
all about getting back to the Bible but
the Reformation was started by a guy who
had no problem criticizing the content
of the Bible something that something
that certainly Protestants today for the
most part certainly the mainstream
would never openly do but in the replica
in Reformation days the people that got
that got this thing kick-started they
did it all the time they were very open
about it in what's interesting too is
that that's not something that you would
have found then or now in the Catholic
Church you're not gonna find now you
might take issue with how the Catholic
Church interpret interprets books but
the Catholic Church is not gonna come
out and say this book is wrong and
shouldn't be taught Luther did say that
here's the main thing but putting that
aside it seems to me that Luther and
Calvin took the epistles of Paul
especially Romans and made those the
central documents of the whole book and
interpreted the whole book that is the
entire canon of scripture through the
lens of paul interpreting even the
teachings of jesus through the lens of
paul so that all the places in the text
where Jesus seems to very explicitly
tell us that our ultimate destination
will depend to some degree on the things
that we do on earth I mean Jesus
indicates this many many many times in
the gospel all over the place in the
gospel and this is a subject that he's
asked about and speaks on frequently
sometimes very directly what can I do to
inherit eternal life keep the
commandments
now and I know that you talk to you
might have an answer for that verse
because I don't know he didn't mean it
like that but what you do with all those
various verses where Jesus seems to
really indicate not just indicate but
say that to some degree it's going to
depend on the things you do so what
you'll probably do is you'll say no no
that's not how he meant it here's what's
meant and then the next thing you're
gonna do and this is my experience
almost every time out comes book of
Romans so it seems like what you're
doing is you're reading Jesus
through the filter of Paul now in my
view it should be the opposite we should
read Paul through the filter of Jesus
and wherever one teaching seems to need
to be subordinated to another maybe
that's not exactly the right term I'm
not saying I don't mean supplanted or
replaced I don't mean that they
contradict but what I mean is that you
know one of those teachings has to be
the foundation for the other and I think
that the teachings of Jesus are the
foundation for Paul not the other way
around so when you've got Paul saying
salvation by faith and you've got Jesus
saying the ones who make it to heaven be
the ones who clothe the naked and fed
the hungry and we're trying to figure
out how to make it all fit we should
begin with the assumption that there is
some way to interpret Paul that will fit
within Christ's framework rather than
beginning with the assumption that there
is some way to interpret Christ that
will fit within Paul's framework so that
is my that's my my point and and so in
this is an interesting discussion we
could continue it I'd be happy to but I
just I want to make the point that if
you're in the Protestant tradition you
are fought you are following an
interpretation of the Bible that was
handed down to you by men like Luther
whether you know it or not so you're not
just coming up with it on your own you
know if you had no idea of any of this
and you were not brought up in any
tradition whatsoever and you were to
just pick up the Bible or read it which
this is the way people pretend they read
the Bible where they know influence
they're picking up and reading it I
submit to you that if you were to do
that without any influence of any
traditions of men as you put it there is
no way you would arrive on your own at
the conclusion that you know that that
it all boils down to Romans and that
everything has to be seen through that
lens I just don't think there's any way
you get through all those books and
everything including the you know the
four Gospels where the Son of God is
talk is giving teachings
and then and then get to Rome and say
okay this is everything right here that
what I'm saying is that is one way to
interpret it but I don't think that's
your interpretation I think that's
interpretation that was given to doesn't
mean it's wrong I think it is wrong but
just because it was given to you by
someone else doesn't mean it's wrong and
in fact I think that as I said nobody
picks up the Bible and freely interprets
it without any influence no one does
that even if they claim they do and it's
good that no one does that actually
because I don't think that's the right
way of approaching the Bible I think
that we do need some help and guidance
in making sense of it and anyone who has
just picked it up and read it from the
first page and just read on like it was
a novel or something which it isn't but
anyone who has read it that way
you you you you it doesn't take you long
before you start encountering things and
you say I I don't I'm not sure what this
means I can't figure out how to make
sense of it and so that's where you go
to solve you get you go somewhere to
help you to figure out how to make sense
of it don't you so you have your place
that you go I have my place we could
talk about which place is the right way
to go my only point is you can't pretend
that you don't have a place you go for
your interpretation and because you do
which in and of itself is fine and I
think unavoidable and so much of
interpreting Scripture comes down to
finding these various when you have
these various teachings so much of
interpretation comes down to figuring
out what lens to see it through in other
words when you've got two teachings that
appear to contradict even though they
don't appear to interpretation so often
is do I view do I do I view passage be
through the lens of a or do I view
passage a through the lens of B and the
decision you make there depending on
what the passages are is going to be it
is going to determine so much of your
theology but how did you
decide that original thing you've got
two passages how do you know which one
because the Bible itself doesn't contain
a glossary or an index explaining in
itself how to do this and especially in
the New Testament the New Testament
books rarely refer to each other
sometimes they do but rarely and so
you're not gonna often find in the book
explaining where the book says okay
here's what it's saying here but oh that
other book remember that it says this
here's how to read those two things
together the Bible doesn't do that for
you and so you have to decide how to
view it and again I would suggest that
your decision there on how to view it is
not is probably not something you you
actually came up with yourself alright
interesting subject though so thanks for
that
thank you for that question we'll leave
it there thanks everybody for watching
listening have a great weekend Godspeed
Matt Walsh show is produced by Robert
Sterling associate producer alexia
Garcia Del Rio executive producer Jeremy
boring senior producer Jonathan hey our
supervising producer is Mathis Glover
and our technical producer is Austin
Stevens edited by Donovan Fowler audio
is mixed by Mike Cora Mena the Matt
Walsh show is a daily wired production
copyright daily wire 20 19
if you prefer facts over feelings aren't
offended by the brutal truth and you can
still laugh at the insanity filling our
national news cycle well tune in to the
ben shapiro show we will get a whole lot
of that and much more see you there